[Musique]
isabella ni de votre mot préféré
affronter lumière le mot que vous dites
oui oui parce que ça contient la paix
l'amour dieu puis c'est la chose qu'on
voit qu'on a à la naissance et qu'on a
la mort
et puis la lumière c'est le cinéma les
frères lumière le mot que vous détestez
sida parce que c'est la perte cesser la
mort c'est celle incurable au temps
présent notre drogue favorite du sucre
le son le bruit que vous aimez tout ce
qui tout ce qui me fait croire au
silence c'est à dire c'est peut être la
musique ça peut être les oiseaux c'est
peut être les feuilles c'est peut être
la neige tout ce qui est froissement
glissement et le son le web vous
détestez
je crois tout ce qui pétaradent j'aime
pas les machines votre juron aux gros
mot blasphème favori alors là alors là
il ya beaucoup à n'a pas mal on a
récemment que j'ai appris que kate un
juron irlandais et qui est tellement
jolie mais bon ça que c'est un mot
terrible c'est ging guiraud tellement
douce il peut très bien daniel connu un
mot fameux pour illustrer nouveau billet
de banque
sigmund freud parce que c'est le mérite
vu que c'est la première personne qui
nous a raconté que l'argent ne voulait
pas dire l'argent le métier que n'auriez
pas aimé faire alors là je sèche
franchement je sais je sais je sais pas
je sais pas laplante l'arbre l'animal
dans lequel vous aimeriez être réincarné
par exemple un gorille pour oui oui mais
c'est sexuel tellement c'était ce serait
dans le but d'organiser devant d'état
contre les hommes pourra faire alors
enfin une espèce en voie de disparition
parce que parce que vu les autres cités
qui sont qui ont été commises au rwanda
et au zaïre c'est à dire le travail de
certains hommes pour vendre aux
touristes des pâtes des mains de gorille
pour en faire des cendriers mais je
trouve qu'il devrait faire la même chose
avec les donc si j'étais gorille oui
donc vieux on reviendra la violence un
oui c'est ma vendetta moi et si dieu
existe qu aimeriez vous l'entendre vous
dire après votre mort vous isabelle
adjani
alors d'abord j'espère que à ce moment
là les les mots on n'aura plus besoin de
mot humain et que ça pourra se passer
dans une antre guillemets fusion
cognitives mais s'ils ne jamais y avait
des mots à entendre ce serait votre vie
n'a pas encore commencé
[Musique]